yo what's up it's Alex I oh no I'm here
with BuzzFeed and we're gonna talk about
my first my first nickname this is
actually a good one to start with
because technically my nickname is Alex
because I was originally born Martin
Alexander I oh no my dad's name was
Martin and he didn't want to me to be
called the same thing he'd like I don't
know my dad wasn't as 1996 was a weird
year I guess but he wanted me to be
named after him but didn't want me to be
called the same thing so that there was
never confusion so they called me Alex
so I guess technically my first nickname
is Alex my first big singing gig well we
got a define big I guess for me like
singing in church was big as a kid but
then also you know I was in musicals as
a kid I remember in second grade I
played one of the barbershop quartet and
music man so that was pretty big and
like the school play
I remember talent shows and first grade
where we we did me and my sisters did a
lip sync to hey ah by Outkast so let's
just say I've booked and blessed since
you know 2001 my first cell phone I
think my first cell phone was just like
when you you know when you go to Verizon
or whatever phone service place you go
to and they they just give you the phone
like you don't mind my parents weren't
like it wasn't a nice phone at all it
was like I remember you could you could
text this way and it was like the number
like the dial texting or you could turn
it sideways and like slide it up it
wasn't a nice one it was definitely the
one that you could get for like a like a
congratulations phone like hey here you
go if you want a real phone get these
ones but this is the one you can
definitely have now and that was it
first celebrity that followed you on
social media Bella Thorne was the first
celebrity I remember I would just moved
to LA first year I had lived here I was
working in babyface a studio and I
remember they were working with Bella
and Pia Mia actually but it was mainly
Bella and she told me I looked like
Taylor Lautner and she followed me and
then tweeted a picture of me and was
like he looks like Taylor Lautner if you
can find this BuzzFeed and you put it in
the video go go you but it was like it
was like Disney bella thorne still
so very very like young and innocent and
like and and before you know before she
became the little sick which wicked
human then she is now my first pet the
first one that I remember is Taj which
was a Great Dane big old dog and I loved
him first time I realized I was
recognized in public
I actually remember exactly when it was
who was on Renaldi in Granada Hills at
the in and out I just finished filming
season 1 of this awesomeness TV show
that I was on called royal crush and I
remember I went to in and out with my
with one of my best friends in the whole
world Dillon and one of his homies and
his homey was like oh alex is gonna get
recognized and I like laughs does
literally like Asian I'm not gonna get
like that that's not a thing for me I
remember we went to in-and-out and and
we walked in I swear to you it was me
Dillon his homey and then two girls
that's it the whole in and out just us
and these two girls and though the two
girls came up and they're like are you
Alex and I was like what the heck so big
shots too Sam literally manifested me
getting recognized for the first time my
first Instagram post that's fine I don't
I don't even know let's figure it out I
think I've deleted a lot of posts since
the first one off the top of my head I
think my first Instagram post was
Pillsbury Crescent rolls
literally on a countertop it not cooked
yet either like raw Pillsbury Crescent
rolls we're gonna find out while we
swipe to tell you about the next one
my first job if we don't count music
which I don't ever count because I
actually do really enjoy it even though
it is work but I don't think of it as
like a job my first job was when I was
18 years old I worked at All Saints the
clothing store and I worked there for
about three weeks then right after it
was right when I booked that awesomeness
TV show and I ended up just doing that
instead so the only job I ever worked
outside of making music I did I did
enjoy it I got I remember I got his
girl's number and I ended up hanging out
there
a little drizzly date that sounds like a
Drake date and I don't know what a Drake
dates like okay so I got to the bottom
of it and this definitely isn't the
first post I must have deleted older
posts for I don't know why but the first
post that I have was opening up for
bridgit mendler it looks like New
Jersey's Six Flags
I think it's called Great Adventure Six
Flags Great Adventure first song I wrote
first time I wrote it was called always
yours I believe
I remember the course was take my time
take my love baby what is - always yours
always oh that would have been so cool
if I would have had it I don't have
first embarrassing moment on stage 2013
I played a mall show and I had a wired
mic and it was really good no it was
wireless mic that's I remember actually
now and I don't know if I was jumping or
whatever and I completely through the
mic off-state like flan like I I Tom
Brady and launched that bad boy into the
crowd and had to like be like can I get
that back so that's pretty embarrassing
first CD I ever bought I feel like the
first CD I bought was probably one of
the now compilations like now 17 or now
10 or whatever I do vividly remember
getting an iTunes gift card my first
iTunes gift card and I bought the Carter
3 my first mashup oh man what is my
first mashup back to the phone we're
using the phone a lot on this one it is
a mash-up of Katy Perry's wide awake and
Rihanna's where have you been hold on
time oh I didn't even say my last name
right look oh no Alex aw no no wonder
nobody says my name right I don't see my
name right it's I oh no that's literally
I oh no and listen bus those are two
different people that I was probably the
third or fourth video I ever put on
YouTube first one was like a trickshot
second one was I was in a flash mob and
I filmed that and the third one was like
a regular straight-up cover of I just
saw secrets by OneRepublic
and that mashup my first celeb crush
probably would be Jessica Alba as the
Invisible Woman in Fantastic Four oh oh
you kidding are you
that's insane I think about right now
and I'm like wow Jill's my first musical
inspiration John Legend for sure I
remember my parents went to with John
Legend concert and came back with the CD
and they played it and I was just like
absolutely enamoured by the level of
soul and like raw emotions and feelings
and the musical ability that I that I
just saw and I could feel through the
music was insane and so definitely still
one of my biggest inspirations and and
one of my favorite memories in life will
always be when I got to work with them
and and write I think the first time I
wrote with him and met him I was very
like shy and timid and couldn't really I
didn't care about what I had to say like
I didn't care at all what I had to say
and so that was definitely we didn't I
don't even remember necessarily the song
that we did on that day but then I wrote
again with him at his house maybe like a
couple months later and that's when we
worked and we once when we wrote the
song young and foolish together I
remember his energy of being just like
super positive like it just felt like we
don't remember writing the song I just
remember finishing the song and
recording it but I do remember also he
put me on the spot because my manager
told him that I play a cover of ordinary
people and he literally made me play him
the cover of ordinary people in front of
him on his piano at his house it was so
nerve-wracking but I did it and it was
tight I did not mean Chrissy I want to
she's such a queen and the last one
we're empty now my first kiss wasn't
we've all been waiting for the juicy one
my first kiss I will it was summer of
seventh grade and I kissed her in her
mom's bathroom and that's I think speaks
for itself
I kissed her in her mom's bathroom and
mr. Taye the dog was born you know I
mean it's the day I became a man and I
manned up and I closed mouth kissed a
girl gosh
[Music]
[Music]